[Music]
let's go to michelle
in portland oregon what's up michelle
how are you
hey good morning dr john how are you i'm
good what's going on in your world
um well not much uh oh sorry i'm a
little nervous
hey i'm nervous too and i promise you're
better at this than me so
go ahead okay all right um well
not really sure how to say this but i
just found out recently that
my husband has a felony conviction
from before we were married okay and
it's also registered sex offender oh
okay that kind of felony
yeah so um hey can i ask you something
have you told anybody this uh my mom
she's the only one i've talked to other
than you i guess now um
can you do me a favor yes do a favor i
want you to breathe in real real deep
and hold it for a second
and then let it out
i can hear it sitting on you yeah
when did you find out about this um
actually it's been
probably about almost two months now but
okay
still kind of comes up on occasion
yeah i can imagine so that you're like
hey pass the potatoes
what the f like yeah i i totally could
see that
so how did you find out
um actually a piece of his mail um i
found
that his yearly has to uh register every
year with the state
and so they send him like a little
notice saying you have to pay your fine
every year to register
and i found it in the mail um
how long have you been married five
years
do you all have kids we do and that's
kind of part of my question
how many um we have two kids together
we have uh two-year-old twin daughters
and i have a 13 year old son from a
previous relationship
so y'all are in this yes five years
and what is his explanation of what
happened why he's on the registry
um well he
was in college um at the time so this
was about 15 years ago when it happened
and he was just at a party
and he spent a night with a young woman
who happened to be under the age that he
didn't know
um it was one night and he didn't find
out until about a week later when the
cop knocked on his door
that's what he said i got all the
paperwork from the courts and everything
he didn't spend any jail time he just
had some fines and three years of
probation
and why did he hide this from you
well he says he didn't hide it he just
didn't tell me he's
thought that when we first started
dating we kind of mentioned something
about running background checks on each
other
um and he thought that i saw it on there
and
that it might not have bothered me
it was kind of what his explanation was
so i am
not about it i am way way
if that story is true if you went looked
at the court records and that looks
right
i am way way way way more worried
that he lied to you that for five years
he's hidden this from you
because he must have had to go to the
mail before you got there every year
to go re-register what's he do for a
living
uh he's like a welder okay
so what'd your mom tell you to do
uh she really she came over that day
because when i first got the
the notice in the mail i didn't really
know what it was because
it's just pretty much says you're a sex
offender and no you knew what it was you
didn't want to believe what it was
right i didn't believe it but i didn't
know what type of effects
what it was for was it really for like
did he
really go after a woman um
or was it like what he said um happened
where it was just a one-night
relationship and he didn't know that she
was underage because he was at a college
party
but but hold on i i don't want to
minimize that
rape is rape is rape right right right
and 15 years ago yes i get that a long
time ago yes i get all that stuff
but it's a college person's
responsibility
if they're going to be wheeling and
dealing right now we have a whole other
conversation be a whole other podcast to
talk about
is it right to to be labeled 15 years
later and all this and that
all that isn't pertinent right now
what's right now
is this guy's a sex offender
you got married you got kids by him and
he's somebody that i would have a hard
time trusting right now
and what you're gonna have to do is
decide a am i going to reestablish trust
with this person how about this you got
to back out what you all had before now
is completely over
right okay and if you don't start there
you're going to drive yourself crazy
okay
so this idea that everything's perfect
and this is what was
is over there's a period at the end of
that sentence and you're going to have
to have a season of grieving
that you got had
okay that doesn't mean this thing's over
it doesn't mean that you can't not be
with him
but that does mean now fully wrapping
your head around
i am married to a sex offender right
wrong or different
and here's the other thing you're gonna
have to be really graceful
with you because you're gonna beat
yourself up over this
have you already done that yeah i have
yeah don't do that okay you got had
you got lied to and you can say
i wasn't hiding it you don't just leave
this off this is a conversation
you have before good god almighty
i understand not having this
conversation on date one fair
you gotta have this conversation before
you get married you gotta have this
conversation before you have kids with
somebody
period
and you can't say oh i thought you knew
come on man
come on right
so what are you gonna do
um i thought about that for a lot i i
still love them and i mean on
some days it's starting to get to where
you know i don't think about it
and i'll go whole day without thinking
about it and then the next day i think
about it
yeah um and and we're still doing great
you know the first you know about month
was pretty hard but we're doing a lot
better
um we're looking at possibly going to
speak to somebody
so i'd like to try and make it work good
very cool what why why did your your
were you married before no i was not
okay
um but you're you have a 13 year old in
the house
correct okay um yeah
a hundred percent you'll have to go see
somebody okay
and he again i am way more concerned at
this point 15 years later
that he lied to you and
that's gonna continue it's gonna it's
gonna be a seed in your relationship
it's going to
it's going to grow and fester if you
don't deal with it right now
and so he's still not coming clean with
you he's still unlocked united said hey
i lied to you
i hid this from you i didn't i thought
you were wonderful and i thought you
would leave if you found out
he needs to be that kind of honest with
you
okay and until he does you're gonna
try to make this all go away and it's
just not going to
and you're gonna have to have a response
for
when a neighbor comes by or a future
realtor comes by
somebody's going to pull up that
registry and go what in the world
and this is going to have to be a part
of y'all's life not something you'll
hide and try to but
this is going to be a part of your life
right
and at some point you have to sit down
and tell your son because your son's
gonna get someone's gonna look it up at
school
and someone's gonna say what about your
debt you're gonna have to have that
conversation too
and hopefully your husband's of the
caliber now where he would take your son
out before he goes to school and say hey
here's something that happened to me
here's something i'm going to pay for
for the rest of my life
here's how you honor and treat people
here's how you are a steward of
people around you here's our student of
your own body you're gonna have to have
those conversations
right you can redeem this thing but it's
man it has to start with
unadulterated clear the deck honesty and
yet you don't have that yet
right i hate that for you michelle
oh it's heartbreaking you're gonna have
to let yourself off the hook for this
okay you are most of us
get married we know somebody we love
that somebody we've been so 85 years
we don't think oh you know what i need
to do i need to go ahead and check the
we just don't do that
right i hate that for you michelle
listen sit down and have the hard
conversation
you start over that's what's happening
here you're starting over clear the deck
and go get a professional to help you
all walk through this
okay there's gonna be a season of
grieving a season of rebuilding
if you choose to stay with him and then
a season of
how do we do something completely
different than we've done before because
it's got
anything moving forward it's got to be
built on truth all right thanks michelle